So today, we talked about diagnosis which is a term we're very familiar with
from our everyday lives. But today, we talked about it specifically in
a knowledge-based AI sense. We started off by defining diagnosis,
which is finding the fault responsible for the malfunction in some system.
This can be computers, computer programs, cars or even people and animals.
We then talked about the process of diagnosis, mapping data onto hypotheses and
how we can see this as a form of classification. We discovered though that this
can be a very complicated process and classification might not get
us all the way there. So then we talked about diagnosis as a form of abduction.
Given a rule and effect or a symptom, we can abduce the cause of that problem,
like an illness or a software bug. Both configuration and diagnosis have been
small tasks in the broader process of design. Now that we talk about them,
we can talk about AI agents that can actually do design in the real world,
as well as what it would mean for an AI agent to really be creative.